yeah it does Donnell me that I could do
a video about anything I want I'm doing
it on this straight to DVD and blu-ray
movie curse of chucky it's just just
that what's going down cuz I wanted to
curse of chucky so curse of chucky is
the new movie starring the psycho killer
doll Chucky who contains the soul of
Charles Lee ray knees all homicidal and
he kills folks this is kind of it's his
thing I saw preview for this and I was
like no matter what I don't care I've
never done a video on a straight to
blu-ray and DVD movie I don't think that
I can recall anyway and I was like I'm
doing one on that cuz I have a soft spot
in my heart for those damn Chucky movies
guilty pleasure if ever there was one
they got campy is [ __ ] later on this one
looks like it was a return to form you
know it's like just Chucky in a house
and he's slaughtering a family and Brad
Dourif plays the voice of Chucky again
funny enough the main chick in this
movie's Brad Dourif
daughter yeah that guy produced that
chick good job Brad Dourif DNA and was
it fun seen Chucky slaughter people yeah
it's actually a sequel it does actually
tie into the other Chucky movies all of
them more or less I really forgot how
the last couple movies the Bride of
Chucky and seated Chucky ended I I don't
know how they ended because I they're
not good I don't have to remember
everything about a guilty pleasure I'm
saying the first three Chucky movies are
guilty pleasures to me because I had
Chucky fest with my brother when I was
in junior high in high school and that
was fun it did not include the last two
Chucky movies however in it being a
return to form they try to do in this
movie what a 1980s Chucky movie what try
to do is that it doesn't really show
Chucky doing things until about 40
minutes into the movie I mean this
person dies and you see the person dead
you don't see who did it and it's
supposed to be mysterious but at this
point there's no mystery at all we know
Chucky is a psycho doll who kills people
so let's just get on with that is what
we really want to see you're not making
a Twilight Zone special here there
doesn't need to be all that intrigue
it's not intrigue it does come across as
boring seriously the first 40 minutes of
this movie is kind of boring it would be
interesting if you had believable and
realistic characters but you don't when
you have a movie that has a bunch of
people who look like porn stars and
their acting is the intrigue is out the
window at that point your brand
doing okay I don't need to take this
seriously anymore so there's no intrigue
I just want to see slaughter and mayhem
Ella that's not here kind of boring then
Chucky shows his true colors and after
that is pretty cool he's Charles Lee
Rainie sounds the same guess that creepy
yell that he does when he runs after
someone's Oleg's are like as a Chucky
movie does have some cool elements in it
it's not the return to form
awesome Chucky movie that Chucky fans
really want it to be but it's not
complete [ __ ] terrible either the
physics are [ __ ] things happen where
you're like that wouldn't happen Chucky
pushes this chick and her wheelchair
hits a guy and the guy flips over her
and lands on the ground like that
wouldn't happen like that but this is a
movie where a dollar slaughtering people
that wouldn't happen either the ending
of this movie was pretty cool you get
the feeling this might be the last
Chuckie movie and in that it's a pretty
cool send off this movie suffers from
what a lot of horror movies suffer from
when they're a return to form to their
previous roots tries to come across as a
return to form to what you love but it
comes across it's about two and a half
decades outdated and when they start
tying things into the past and previous
lawyer-like this feels a lot like scream
3 I'm just saying it does in the end
curse of chucky is clearly a straight to
DVD and blu-ray movie I can see why it
is the acting is not that great the
first 40 minutes of this movie is pretty
slow it picks up when Chucky shows
himself and he starts doing his Chucky
thing and that's cool I thought the
ending was pretty cool not a great movie
but it's probably a great time if you're
drunk yeah now is the party a party to
die for one weird thing though Chucky
gets its head popped off and it just
pops off like a lego Chucky always had
like guts inside like if he severed his
head it would just be like spraying
blood and wasn't like that this time I
was kind of weird to me I was like yo
how are so Chucky movies what is your
favorite Chucky movie out of all of them
whatever it is comment below let me know
and actually make it least favorite also
that it has a pretty broad spectrum and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you